announced Senator Tom Cottons here
welcome back to our program and good
morning to you today here are the
numbers along the southern border to
date and 20 fiscal year to date 1.9
million
so we're going to top 2 million easily
bus to Washington 9400 as of today New
York City to 1100 Chicago 500 now we've
got a few dozen in Martha's Vineyards
here your reaction to this back and
forth now
Bill the hypocrisy of these
sanctimonious liberals is just amazing
Joe Biden has presided over a slow
motion invasion of our country since he
took office almost 4 million illegal
migrants have crossed our country and
there are border towns to include El
Paso as we just heard from Bill melugin
who have thousands of illegal migrants
arriving every single day yet when a few
thousand arrive in Washington DC they
declare a state of emergency when they
get to Chicago they call out the
National Guard when 50 get to Martha's
Vineyard the liberal media goes into a
five alarm fire these communities
are so hypocritical because they are not
willing to Bear the brunt of Joe Biden's
immigration failures and remember Joe
Biden is doing the exact same thing he's
transporting migrants all around the
country it's just liberals want to
decide where illegal migrants go and
apparently all the rich Elite on
Martha's Vineyard don't want them in
their communities so why should working
class communities in Arizona and Texas
have to bear that burden Senator more
fundamentally what I would say
continue go ahead Sandra what I would
say is that that that uh you know Doug
Ducey and uh Greg Abbott and the people
of Arizona and Texas I'm sure they would
much rather than sending buses and
planes to the north that Joe Biden
actually do his job and protect our
border and send those buses and planes
to the South because these illegal
migrants should be going back to their
home countries they shouldn't be going
anywhere in America
yesterday we were we took it live the
White House Press briefing happened
following the vice president's comments
over the weekend that the border is
secure obviously Republicans are
directly responding to those comments
the press secretary was given a chance
to walk those words back she instead
chose to Double Down listen
okay so Kareem Jean-Pierre backed up the
claim that Kamala Harris has claimed
that the border is indeed secure so I'll
ask you they're touting these numbers
that they are apprehending they're
removing or expelling more migrants than
ever at the southern border Senator but
put that in context for us one needs to
point out that there are more migrants
than ever pouring over our border so
they're having to expel or remove more
migrants than ever
yeah that's exactly right Sandra we've
had almost four million illegal migrants
cross into our country since Joe Biden
took office and I want to be clear this
is not the result of incompetence this
is not an accident this is not a bad
luck for the bind Administration this is
their deliberate policy this is exactly
what they wanted it's what Joe Biden and
Kamala Harris campaigned on you saw
yesterday that the press secretary
wouldn't even say Margaret shouldn't
come to this country they wouldn't even
send the message that you shouldn't make
the very dangerous journey to try to get
to our borders because they are inviting
illegal migrants from all across our all
across the world to come to our country
this is the exact results that the Bible
Administration wanted yet when it
imposes hardship on Democratic
communities like Martha's Vineyard or
Washington D.C they go to Defcon one
about it when they're doing the exact
same thing in communities all across the
country thank you Senator Tom subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world changing your life
from Tucker Carlson tonight